the labor MP bambos such Sarah Lambos
has been suspended from the party over a
complaint about his behavior well let's
go straight to Westminster our political
correspondent Liz Bates is there Liz
what more can you tell us about this
oh we can't we can't tell you that much
more at the moment what we do know is
bambo sharolambos uh it seems like has
had the whip suspended uh from the labor
party today he's the ninth labor MP to
have the whip suspended since 2019 he is
the MP for Enfield Southgate elected in
2017 he was serving as a shadow Minister
for the Middle East and North Africa
he's been in post since 2021 he's
tweeted today I am aware that there is
an allegation that requires
investigation by the labor party it is
right and proper that process is allowed
to take place he says he will cooperate
fully and it is not appropriate to say
anything more at this time so it seems
like a formal complaint has gone in
against him to the labor party their
independent complaints process will now
kick in and that will play out and at
some point
um we will get the results if you like
of that investigation